this video is brought to you by appsumo
the leading digital marketplace for
entrepreneurs
hi
welcome to another episode of cold
fusion where i cover anything in science
technology business or history
imagine a device fraught with such
complexity that it caused an apple
employee to sadly end his own life and
caused another employee to end up in
prison this happened in the early 1990s
with the apple newton project a mobile
device with a touchscreen and apps
apple was looking to start a revolution
but all they got was failure and
personal disaster behind the scenes
so what happened why did the newton fail
and what can be learned
sit back and get comfortable as we take
a look into apple's greatest failure
you are watching cold fusion tv
[Music]
in 1992
apple then known as apple computer was a
completely different place to what it is
today
steve jobs had been forced out of the
company seven years earlier in 1985 and
john scully previously of pepsico was at
the helm
he was a master of marketing but didn't
know much about technology a fact that
would prove disastrous later
apple itself hadn't produced a hit
product since the original macintosh in
1985 and the company needed its next big
break
the 1990s was an odd time for technology
a place before the smartphone and
mainstream internet but it was also a
time after home computing had been well
established the hottest new idea for
technology at the time was the personal
digital assistant or pda
its aim was mainly to organize schedule
and plan
the first true pda was released in 1991
by persian the next year in 1992 apple
would venture into this product category
the original idea for the newton came
from apple engineer steve suckerman he
had some previous experiences in
portable technology after building the
hp 110 the world's first battery-powered
microsoft-based pc and it was released
in 1984 in sacramento's view there was a
hidden future beyond the pc
steve jobs liked what sacrament had done
with the hp portable computer and would
hire him at apple to create a portable
version of the macintosh in 1984
[Music]
the next year however steve jobs was
forced out of apple and without the
guidance of jobs sacrament became
disillusioned within apple he was
reduced to overseeing the hardware teams
for the apple ii and macintosh product
lines he was tempted to leave apple as
he was bored with the work but fellow
apple employee jean-louis garcia
convinced sacrament to build a team
within apple to experiment with new
ideas
in 1987 the team was approved and the
group would grow quickly
steve sacrament gathered a team of
engineers and moved into an abandoned
warehouse in cupertino they got to work
brainstorming and building
the new device for now in their
imagination would be called the apple
newton reason being the original apple
logo was isaac newton sitting under a
tree so the name newton made sense
the newton researchers began work on an
ipad-like device
steve sacrament envisioned a tablet
computer the size of a folded a4 sheet
of paper the price was to be the same as
a desktop computer at the time
being aware of all the developments
going on in tech at the time he
incorporated touch screens hand
recognition a hard disk and even an
infrared port so newtons could
communicate with each other wirelessly
separately apple upper management had
been toying with a similar idea
ceo john scully commissioned two
high-budget video mock-ups of a product
called the knowledge navigator in 1986
here's a sample
[Music]
let me see the lecture notes from last
semester
no that's not enough
i need to review more recent literature
pull up all the new articles i haven't
read yet journal articles only
fine your friend joe gilbert has
published an article about deforestation
in the amazon excuse me
jill gilbert is calling back
great put her through
hi mike what's up is this one of your
typical last minute panics for lecture
material
it would be great if you were available
to make a few comments nothing formal
you know i have a simulation that shows
the spread of the sahara over the last
20 years here let me show you
nice very nice i've got some maps of the
amazon area during the same time let's
put these together
hmm interesting i can definitely use
this
thanks for your time jill i really
appreciate it no problem
but next time i'm in berkeley you're
buying the dinner
dinner right see ya 4 15.
bye-bye
while you were busy your mother called
again to remind you to pick up the
birthday cake
fine fine i know um princess article
before i go
now printing
okay i'm going to lunch now
unfortunately for the newton team the
reality of late 1980s technology didn't
really live up to the dream prototype
tablets had major issues
handwriting recognition just didn't work
different writing styles were proving
impossible for the device to understand
and with handwriting being the primary
input method for the device this was a
disaster eventually the software was
improved a little but still needed a
large amount of work
meanwhile apple as a company was still
doing okay but was becoming over-reliant
on the sales of the macintosh computer
to make matters worse compact gateway
and dell were all on the rise with only
less than 10 of the computing market
things were going to get a whole lot
worse for apple perhaps the newton being
a completely new product category was
just the thing apple needed to turn
things around
meanwhile a second team with an apple
was also working on a portable device
called the pocket crystal it had three
processors a battery that lasted for
weeks at a time and weighed eight pounds
or 3.6 kilograms
however the cost would be 8 000 us
dollars
due to separate internal struggle
sacrament left apple in 1990 the project
would continue though under the
leadership of larry tesla formerly of
xerox park he was impressed by the
newton and provided a detailed
demonstration to apple's upper
management in 1991
john scully loved the idea and decided
to run with it over the pocket crystal
interestingly the pocket crystal would
later spin out into a separate company
called general magic a company that
almost invented an iphone-like device
but failed just at the last moment
this may be a story for another episode
so it was 1991 scully had the
revolutionary product that was going to
save apple a tablet computer with a
touchscreen
although the screen was resistive touch
and had no multi-touch capabilities it
was to be revolutionary for its time
such a device was a new concept so the
team argued about what size it should be
the original plan was to have three
models
a nine by twelve inch model costing
about five thousand dollars and then a
six by nine inch model costing two
thousand and a four point five by seven
inch costing five hundred
after much arguing it was decided that
the smaller size would be the best
option
john scully would make a plan for the
newton to ship in april of 1992 a tight
deadline by any standard he was so
excited that he didn't wait for the
development to finish before announcing
it to the public in january of 1992 he
made the announcement at the consumer
electronics show in las vegas
a public demo would be held in chicago a
few months later
scully while being able to sell the idea
of the newton didn't understand the
intricacies of getting the device
consumer ready so the apple engineers
got to work and work they did they were
trying to kill thousands of bugs during
this time 15 to 20 hour days weren't
uncommon
as development continued it became clear
that the processor wasn't going to be
powerful enough to keep up with the
software demands so they decided to
switch to an arm processor luckily for
them it turned out both to be faster and
more efficient at running code
they were far from being in the clear
though as the demo drew closer the
newton was still unreliable units would
sometimes get too hot to handle because
of faulty power managers
as the team practiced demonstrations of
key features like faxing and beaming
information wirelessly via infrared the
newton would fail more often than it
succeeded
[Music]
the big day arrived in chicago and apple
showed off their latest device now
called the newton message pad
all of the message pads were tethered to
max they were just too unreliable to run
independently
the engineers demonstrated some shape
recognition and showed off the user
interface
the press was a light with excitement
and to them it seemed like the newton
was ready to ship
but behind the scenes the device was far
from being done
for the apple engineers there was a sigh
of relief but then a slow realization
that this had become the ultimate
pressure cooker situation
as development continued more problems
arose getting the newton consumer ready
was proving to be a massive challenge
the release date was pushed back to
august 1993 the press became unhappy
about this and labelled the device
vaporware
the company would showcase the product
again at the consumer electronics show
in 1993 this time without tethering to a
macintosh
[Music]
in an effort to get the product ready
countless weeks of 16-hour days took its
toll on many of the apple employees
working on the newton project
some quit and others simply cried
relationships suffered and mental health
was left in the dust
according to the new york times as the
deadline closed in 30 year old software
engineer ko isono couldn't take it
anymore and sadly took his own life in
december of 1992
[Music]
within a week
another programmer had a breakdown
ending up in prison after attacking his
roommate
for those of you who have seen the
making of the iphone documentary all of
this pressure would ring a bell
due to these tragic events apple would
introduce a buddy mental health program
and this was to help engineers who were
on the verge of burning out from intense
work
even a day before the next consumer
electronics show newtons were failing
without warning and the batteries were
getting eaten alive by faulty power
management
the team was not confident in their
success
but miraculously everything worked as
planned on the day
as the software moved into beta in may
almost 4 000 bucks were found
most of these were sorted by the end of
the month but it was still too buggy to
ship
the staff were pushed even harder than
ever before
finally despite all of this the newton
message pad rolled out in august of 1993
at macworld
by this point much of the original hype
had died down as it was over a year past
its original launch date
it had also promised too much the
wireless features which were a major
selling point didn't make it at launch
selling for 6.99 the first version of
the newton could recognize printed and
hand-written text it had a library of a
thousand words and could learn more like
a modern smartphone does today
[Music]
because of the buggy software the early
press sentiment wasn't positive even the
simpsons would make a mockery of the
handwriting recognition
hey dolph take a memo on your newton
beat up martin
although there was an on-screen keyboard
handwriting was the primary method of
interfacing with the device so buggy
text recognition was less than ideal
by 1995 in a newer version called the
message pad 120 a lot of these software
bugs were fixed
in 1997 apple would spin off the newton
division into a new company
they would be in charge of selling the
best version yet the message pad 2000
it had a relatively quick 166 megahertz
processor a larger two megabytes of
removable storage one megabyte of ram
and a higher 480p resolution display
and though the screen would still be
hard to read at times it would be a
modest success it finally looked like
the newton would be the future direction
of apple
the newton company even got their own
logo apple employees and even a separate
board of directors
apple was losing money in 1997 so the
plan was to gain outside investment into
the new newton company
the standalone newton company would go
public in 1999 it wasn't to be though as
soon as steve jobs took back control of
apple in 1998 he made the decision to
cut the newton project completely steve
jobs wanted to focus the company's
efforts in a more concentrated and
cohesive direction
in its five years on the market the
newton only sold around 200 000 units
for comparison in its first five years
the iphone sold over 130 million units
although it was clear that there was
something to be said for mobile
computing back then it was perhaps too
early and too ambitious
looking back from the future it's easy
to see that web browsing would have been
the killer app for the newton but the
first commercial web browser was only
released in 1993
while the newton was being made there
really was no vision of what mobile web
browsing could look like it just didn't
really exist at the time
interestingly a mobile web browser
called hopper was made for the later
versions of the newton but it was too
little too late
ultimately the newton was a product in
search for a problem to solve it was too
expensive for casual buyers but too
underpowered for business users the
newton's legacy does live on as the
great grandfather to all smartphones
and also its popularization of the arm
processor
before we continue i just want to give a
shout out to today's sponsor appsumo as
creators and entrepreneurs we wear a lot
of hats social media project management
sales accounting copywriting just to
name a few
appsumo is the leading digital
marketplace for entrepreneurs and the
best way to automate the busy work that
comes with running a business
last black friday appsumo gave away a
tesla and this year they're taking their
1 million black friday budget and giving
it away to any creator who lists a
product on appsumo there's also an
additional ten thousand dollars for ten
randomly chosen lucky creators
list your product on appsumo before
november the 17th and grab your share of
their one million dollar black friday
marketing fund plus a chance to be one
of ten lucky winners randomly chosen to
win an additional ten thousand dollars
so in summary ultimately three things
doomed the newton number one
early negative press
number two a lack of internet
connectivity and number 3 a ceo who
didn't deeply understand the technology
he was touting or just how much work it
would take to bring it to life in a
polished way
the newton team recognized the loss of
30 year old mr isono in which the
pressure of the project contributed to
him ending his life
if you type in a special command the
newton screen will say in memory of ko
esono
the newton story is one of dedication
personal sacrifice and a product that
was too early promising too much while
delivering too little in the world of
technology timing is everything
if we include the mental toll that it
took on apple's staff and the tragic
loss of mr esono the apple newton was
without a doubt apple's greatest failure
because all of this effort went into a
project that was immediately scrapped
with the return of steve jobs
so what do you guys think
let me know in the comment section below
if you want to discuss this video head
on over to the cold fusion discord if
you want to see a similar episode on the
development of the iphone and the behind
the scenes pressure that went on i'll
leave a link to that cold fusion episode
below as well
anyway that's it from me
my name is degogo and you've been
watching cold fusion and i'll catch you
again soon for the next episode
cheers guys
have a
good me thinking
[Music]